this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
what's up guys michael here and today
we're going to talk about what's perhaps
tom hardy's finest cinematic work
venom
say what you will and critics certainly
did but something about this movie
really resonated with audiences granted
that resonance was often overtly sexual
but
owen's a win right in fact the sequel's
already upon us absurdly titled venom
let there be carnage amidst all the hype
one talking point has really stuck out
to us director andy circus in the actual
production notes characterized the film
as a love story between eddie brock and
the symbiote did not see that one coming
and as wild as it may seem there's
precedent here searches for the term
simbrock exploded upon the movie's
release with the fandom going to bat for
an eddie and symbiote romance it's even
in the source material plenty of comics
characterize their bond as straight up
love so what is it about the symbiotic
bond of a human being and an alien goo
boy that leads people to a romantic
interpretation is there deeper meaning
behind it or are we just looking for
love in all the wrong places grab a
bullet peter dogs and chocolate and
settle in for this wisecrack edition on
venom a love story and spoilers for the
first venom movie and some of the comics
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
surfsharkvpn surfsharkvpn helps you
secure your data with industry-leading
measures by using uncrackable encryption
and the most secure vpn protocols
something i love about surfshark is how
it lets me check out content from around
the world that i otherwise wouldn't be
able to access i hate when i read about
some amazing show or comedy special from
the uk but can't actually watch it but
with surf shark vpn i can simply use one
of their servers to log into bbc iplayer
and let the absurdist comedy wash over
me you can also unblock the 15 largest
netflix libraries around the world and
when you're traveling abroad you can
keep up with your favorite trash reality
shows from back home it's a content
connoisseur's dream one subscription
will allow you to protect all your
favorite devices and there are apps for
all your favorites like pc mac android
chrome firefox amazon fire stick and
even your xbox and playstation search
shark is fast easy to use and jam-packed
with features if you use the link in the
description and use the promo code
wisecrack you can get surfsharkvpn for
83 off its normal annual price plus
three extra months for free go to
surfshark.deals wisecrack or hit the
link in the description protect yourself
online and download surfsharkvpn today
and now back to the show now for a quick
recap venom follows eddie brock an
investigative journalist who's going to
every length to take down a mad
scientist type even if it includes
snooping on his fiancee anne's work
emails while investigating eddie
accidentally merges with an aggressively
deep voiced alien symbiote aka parasite
and chaos ensues so at this point you're
probably thinking this doesn't sound
like the plot of a classic rom-com but
if you take away all the rad action
sequences the film is at its core an
exploration of two intense relationships
eddie and anne and eddie and the
symbiote and key to understanding the
latter comes in the form of their
classic catchphrase
it may seem like simple fan service in
the film but the line is actually very
illuminating see in his essay love's
bond philosopher robert nozick explores
the notion of a love union specifically
he suggests that being in a romantic
pairing or in this case a shared body
bromance with someone actually results
in the formation of a whole new identity
he states with this continuing romantic
love it feels to the two people that
they have united to form and constitute
a new entity in the world what might be
called a we to nozik each party keeps
their individual identity with all of
its accompanying wants hopes and fears
but in fully embracing your partner's
identity you actually combine it with
your own in nozick's wii the couple
feels each other's highs and lows as if
they were their own through this lens
the ending of venom becomes more than an
amazing action set piece it's an
affirmation of the love between eddie
and the symbiote and their embrace of
the close bond that now defines them
they may be at odds for much of the film
it is peaceful up here
i'm not very good with heights but when
they finally declare we
are them and their shared face shows
half eddie and half symbiote it's the
first step in forming and growing their
new shared identity it's a
literalization of a very real phenomenon
that nozick ascribes to a love
relationship the combining of two
separate entities into something new and
different a we nozick says this new
identity as a we
consists of a the two wanting to be
recognized together publicly b the
partners mutually tending to their
collective well-being and c a division
of labor which we especially see in the
trailer for the sequel
excuse me
but of course forming a wii isn't all
fun and games nosik also notes that love
means your own well-being is tied up
with that of someone you romantically
love love can place you at risk though
again it's more of a bromance than
sensual long walks on the beach but we
still see the literalization of this
phenomenon in venom after all the two
literally share a body an experience
which puts eddie in no shortage of risky
situations
and of course forming any partnership
requires making compromises nozick
writes people who form a wii pool not
only their well-being but also their
autonomy they limit or curtail their own
decision-making power and rights some
decisions can no longer be made alone
and that brings us to the most
interesting difference between the
film's two central relationships compare
the way eddie behaves with the symbiote
to the way he behaves with anne he makes
it clear that he values his own goals
and autonomy over hers when he snoops in
her inbox his identity as an
investigative journalist is stronger
than his identity as a romantic partner
and he fundamentally violates anne's
trust which ends up costing her her job
what you did got me fired eddie wasn't
willing to compromise for the sake of
the relationship or to consult anne
about such a massive decision with venom
however eddie takes a decidedly more
considerate approach he is
understandably freaked out by the
symbiotes need to eat people but
compromises nonetheless he communicates
his needs to the symbiote whether it's
his stipulation through they can harm
you cannot just go around eating anybody
that you want to or simply some space to
do his journalistic work i need you to
stay quiet this is a me thing it is not
a we thing you got that fine but make it
quick and of course eddie shares a body
with the symbiote fully surrendering his
own physical autonomy nozick argues that
surrendering some individual autonomy is
actually a desirable aspect of being in
love and that you're yielding to your
union we see both the symbiote and eddie
do just that when they commit to sharing
the same body it's noteworthy that the
partnership that is venom ends the film
walking off to plan their day together
we can do whatever we want meanwhile
eddie's relationship with anne appears
to basically be over at least for now
don't give up on her and nozick's love
union doesn't just apply to the movie
it's also been a common thread
throughout the history of venom as a
property the comic book source material
has been clear that this bond is more
than mere cooperation in one of their
earliest appearances eddie says that the
symbiote has given him things no
girlfriend ever could as their bond grew
venom even straight up called their bond
a marriage nozick states that the heart
of the love relationship is how the
lovers view it from the inside how they
feel about their partner and about
themselves within it and the particular
ways in which they are good to each
other if this is true then most of what
we've looked at so far from comics to
the film adaptation would point towards
venom be an example of how to exist in a
relationship but unfortunately for
anyone using this as a model for their
own relationship that's definitely not
the case they've done truly horrible
things to each other in the comics both
while being bonded and apart the
symbiote has implanted false memories
into eddie's brain to compel him to stay
and eddie has sold the symbiote off to
the highest bidder without so much as a
discussion it's safe to say that in the
end their relationship in the comics has
been the definition of toxic and going
by nozick's theory of love this could
come down to one variable not seen in
the film
spider-man see in the majority of the
adaptations of venom's story the
symbiote actually bonds with spider-man
before he bonds with eddie but the
feelings are ultimately one-sided and
spider-man violently dumps him leaving
him with a burning desire for revenge
this is what drives the symbiote toward
eddie with the goal of killing
spider-man according to nozick this
would be an untenable foundation for
their relationship nozick asserts that
this desire to form a we for its own
sake is key rather than any sort of
transactional or value-based reason
essentially if you are forming the we
because you want something other than
simply to be with your partner the
nozick argues that it's not really love
in other words nozik doesn't think love
can be utilitarian which means you can't
really be in love with someone just
because they own the fanciest hot dog
shop in your town while in the comics
venom does end up in some form of
lovinish attachment this undermines
their union from the get-go and is
arguably what leads to their intensely
toxic behavior in contrast in the movie
the symbiote chooses eddie out of an
appreciation for who he is not how he
can album get what he wants so if the
core of a relationship is treating each
other well then the movie might show us
the best case scenario of eddie and the
symbiote's bond they ultimately decide
to stay together because they share a
mutual understanding even if the
symbiote is a bit harsh about it i have
decided to stay wow on my planet i am
kind of a loser like you they
demonstrate genuine empathy and care for
each other and their cooperation lets
each of them accomplish far more than
they could alone the film is bookended
by eddie's corner store being robbed the
first time eddie stands by helplessly
but the second time venom takes action
that's some
very ravenous teamwork and sure they
might bicker sometimes but what couple
doesn't it's basically when harry met
sally for the modern era so does this
explain why we just can't resist
shipping this unlikely pair well
yes and no their relationship might
closely mirror nozick's philosophical
take on love but there are complicated
truths to contend with not to put two
finer points on it but venom's
essentially a talking pile of gloop even
peak aramaic ryan couldn't make that
seem romantic still the core of venom is
universal two beings get to know each
other like no one else and in turn they
feel like they have to be together they
can tell us that it's a story about
revenge or justice all they want but
despite it being between a screwed up
has-been and some runny alien plato
we know love when we see it
but what do you guys think can two bros
find love in a weird symbiotic
relationship or are people just weird
and willing to romanticize anything so
long as it leads to good fanfic let us
know what you think in the comments
smash that subscribe button like you're
possessed by an intergalactic symbiote
and don't forget to ring that bell
thanks to our glorious patrons be sure
to check out our podcast and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you